the star wars film series is one of the
most commercially and critically
successful franchises in history ticket
sales alone of yielded over 9.5 billion
dollars worldwide to date and that's not
counting merch sales licensing deals and
other profits since its start in 1977
the series has grown from a trilogy of
well-received fantasy movies into a
full-blown worldwide institution plotted
for its ability to excite and inspire
audiences of course this isn't to say
that the Star Wars franchise is
completely perfect far from it fans can
and will pick apart the movies and find
dozens of slip-ups and make a laundry
list of less than awesome moments that
slightly mar the overall pictures but
those little moments would be small
potatoes in comparison to the mistake
Disney has admitted to making with the
Star Wars franchise one that the studio
is trying to remedy as we speak during a
September 2018 interview with The
Hollywood Reporter Walt Disney Company
CEO Bob Iger addressed the fact that
after acquiring Lucasfilm for just over
four billion dollars in 2012 Disney has
churned out one Star Wars movie every
year since 2015 specifically those
movies would be JJ Abrams as Episode
seven the force awakens the series first
anthology film rogue one in 2016 the
Rian Johnson directed Episode eight the
last Jedi in December 2017 and the young
Han Solo movie simply called solo just
five months later in May 2018 when
reporter Matthew Bologna brought up the
seemingly growing impression that Disney
should pump the brakes on it's Star Wars
releases and not put out a new movie
each year
eager surprisingly agreed he actually
admitted that the huge volume of
releases right out of the gate was a
total mistake and even took personal
responsibility for the evident fatigue
inducing misstep Uyghur confessed as I
look back I think the mistake that I
made I take the blame was a little too
much too fast looking ahead the CEO said
that Disney will no longer be producing
Star Wars movies at such an accelerated
pace according to Uyghur fans can expect
some slowdown following the release of
JJ Abrams as episode 9 although no one
should expect the house of mouse to
bring things to a total halt as Eiger
explained the state of Star Wars movies
beyond 20 19 episode 9 will still be
robust just with a little more breathing
room he reminded readers that Game of
Thrones directors David
and DB Weiss are actively developing
their own Star Wars saga about which
very little is currently known last we
heard Rian Johnson was still tinkering
away with development on his own film
trilogy the company is also developing
at least one big-budget TV show for its
upcoming streaming service but this
content Uyghur said will be served up a
little more judiciously but the company
being quote a little more careful about
volume and timing the suggestion that
Disney should throttle down on the Star
Wars movies isn't a particularly new
idea fans and commentators have been
talking about the potential consequences
of Star Wars over saturation for a while
with the once unthinkable term Star Wars
fatigue becoming a frequent talking
point the franchise took a major hit
with the massively underperforming solo
a Star Wars story which essentially
bombed at the box office after a
notoriously troubled production
following that high-profile
disappointment a whole lot of people got
on board with the idea that Disney
strategy for Star Wars was actually
killing interest in the once venerable
franchise the common wisdom was that
Lucasfilm was trying too hard to mimic
the release calendar of Marvel Studios
and it's backfiring in a big way while
there are fans and viewers who are
perfectly happy with the current state
of Star Wars there's a vocal segment of
the fan base that's all but begging for
Disney to get its act together as the
series wraps up the Skywalker saga and
moves on to stories beyond
iger's comments seem to suggest that
those fans are finally being heard
though it's refreshing to hear I grrrrrr
straight up admitting Disney dropped the
ball
is it possible that the damage is
already done that's hard to predict
already some feel that Disney has bigger
problems with its Star Wars approach
than the high volume of releases after
the interview thr writer Graham
Macmillan questioned whether volume and
timing are really to blame and suggested
that perhaps the audience has a problem
with these specific Star Wars movies in
other words a lot of people might just
dislike the stories that Disney is
telling and that's a harder problem to
fix than just stretching out a release
schedule still it seems that the people
in charge at Disney are doing some
serious reflection about how they might
have mangled they're very expensive
space fantasy series a less dense
release schedule is a good start as to
whether or not that will be enough to
bring the magic back to Star Wars that
remains to be seen
[Music]